wenn sie denken sie wissen schon alles
über mich über michael wendler dann
liegen sie ganz schön fall stellen der
vater von michael wendler hat jetzt ein
buch geschrieben das ist ganze 304
seiten dick ja und was da drin steht da
zeigen wir hier ist erste exklusive
einblicke was erst am freitag erscheint
das buch jetzt schon mal einige infos
der wendler um ihn wird sie ruhig jetzt
hat sein vater dieses buch über ihn
geschrieben
angeblich die wahrheit über seinen sohn
ein buch das abrechnet dass aber auch
neue einblicke liefert in das leben die
kindheit die jugend des jungen der
später zum wendler wurde
bild hat dieses buch exklusiv für sie
gelesen und in familien fotoalbum der
entlass geblättert dunkle haare
schüchterner blick der 20-jährige mich
da hat er noch alles vor sich
ausbildung zum speditionskaufmann in der
firma des papas
bernd peters ist jetzt bei mir schön
dass du da bist im studio
du kannst so ein bisschen was verraten
also man weiß ja schon michael wendler
und der vater haben vielleicht nicht so
ganz die beste beziehung um es mal
vorsichtig auszudrücken was würdest du
jetzt sagen ist das buch eine reine
abbrechen oder steckt mehr dahinter
also es ist natürlich eine abrechnung
sind beschimpfungen da drin und viele
negative bewertungen aber wenn man die
mal abzieht dann kriegt man auch ein
ganz gutes bild wie sich der winter
zudem entwickelt hat wie wir ihn heute
kennen
das buch hat ja auch den titel ganz
bescheiden die wahrheit über meinen sohn
michael wendler ist es jetzt eher
subjektiv oder es hat man wirklich die
wahrheit über den wendler es ist
natürlich erstmal papas wahrheit und wir
haben wenn dann dazu natürlich auch
angefragt er hat sich bisher nicht dazu
gemeldet dementsprechend kennen wir
jetzt eine seite davon aber das ist
natürlich eine seite von jemandem der
sehr nadel über jahrzehnte sehr nah an
ihm dran war und dementsprechend weiß
wovon er spricht
glaubst du welche wetter wird darauf
dann auch reagieren vielleicht mit
anwälten oder so bisher hat er immer
reagiert irgendwann wenn sein vater was
gesagt hat und das ist natürlich jetzt
sehr detaillierte einblicke
der vater sagt jedenfalls er hat keine
angst vor anwältin
die sollen ruhig kommen zitat denn er
sage nur die wahrheit und das würde
michael doch zugeben müssen wenn er das
so liest und kannst du noch mal ein
bisschen was verraten war es jetzt genau
darin steht in dem buch ja es gibt sehr
viele anekdoten die sich zu einem
gesamtbild ergeben das ist jetzt nicht
die riesen nachricht die da drin steht
aber es ergibt ein gesamtbild mit sehr
bizarren
anekdoten zum beispiel das wendler
versucht hat in seinen zwanzigern ein
erotik shop zu eröffnen und als das dann
nicht geklappt hat als plötzlich das
geld ausging hat er dann die ganzen
waren mal eben bei papa in den keller
gestellt alles gestapelt wird gesagt das
bleibt jetzt erst mal da und hat das
auch dann erst mal drei wochen da liegen
lassen also solche sachen ergeben schon
ein interessantes bild auf die
persönlichkeit davon mich erwähnt habe
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren